foreign
so this was sent to me via Instagram
appreciate all my Instagram people out
there uh because they will send me
things a lot and they're like oh my gosh
what do you think about this or what do
you think about that and this one came
you know people might send me stuff too
but I don't look at it so I wouldn't
know
you have to you like read the messages
or something is that what you're
supposed to do I am part of the people
these are my people so yes I get on and
talk to people on social media you could
too social media you could too that's
how it works they're real people out
there on the other side that enjoy your
stuff
so much I'm not gonna get on it should
go and talk to them anyway somebody
talking to you and they sent you this
yes and I read the messages because I
read my messages and they're like hey I
want you and Dave talk about it and I
was like oh well perfect we'll be on the
show together so this was from a New
York Times article and the headline was
I've hidden my trust fund for 15 years
do I finally tell my spouse so
ready for this I'm a 44 year old man and
I've been married to my spouse for 10
years we've been together for 15.
unbeknown to my spouse I have a trust
fund that provides me with a monthly
income of 25
000 when we first met I said that I
worked as a consultant and they've never
questioned it my spouse a dedicated
doctor Works long hours and doesn't like
to discuss work when not on the job over
the years I have repeatedly assured my
spouse that they don't need to work as
my income is secure and stable they are
however passionate about their career
and have chosen continue working I
actively serve on various boards but I
have never held a full-time job and
don't plan to our lifestyle is
Comfortably upper middle class and I am
content with that my dilemma is whether
I should reveal the truth about my trust
fund to my spouse my family members have
always advised against disclosing our
financial situation but the weight of
the secret is becoming too difficult to
bear what do you do all day
he sits on boards oh somebody said I
don't know
um play swirtle I wonder how often like
this kind of well we well we know that
spouses hide things from one another
that's a that's a consistent theme
through life like that's a known thing
um but this one was just interesting
because I'm like okay 25 Grand a month I
wonder what she thinks that he does
to earn that
amount of money
so anyways
um what I would tell the name is
withheld they did not disclose the name
of the New York Times article
so yes if anyone out there has this
dilemma no or no one else or the idea
that you have a secret that is too
unbearable to bear that is from your
spouse listen we always teach and talk
about and believe that being on the same
page with your spouse is much better so
coming clean and telling them
anything and everything when it comes to
money anything you are withholding is
not only gonna just lift the weight off
your shoulders that you've been carrying
around having to navigate because I
think about this situation which this is
kind of is true I know it's a little
absurd
but if you do think about it I'm like
the amount of like probably lies and
deception that had to have occurred to
cover the Big Lots to cover the big lie
that's a lot of work in life and I don't
know who has time for that so I'm just
like Free Yourself learning an awful lot
of calories free yourself being a liar
and you've been with your spouse for two
I mean like
I mean I think it's fine and then you
know what she probably still wants to be
a doctor because she's passionate about
her work and that's great
but yeah being upfront honest disclosing
everything
regardless of whether it's a 25 000
trust fund or it's a secret credit card
that you have whatever it is uh you and
your spouse being on the same page is is
crucial to to winning winning long term
yeah so
um yeah you should have disclosed this
day one and you should be continually
you should not have any secrets from
your spouse hello
period
I mean that's just a thing okay you just
cannot build a quality relationship
on Deception
duh okay so your family is screwed up
dude
because your family is telling you that
your money
and you're not needing to work
is is
you how they know your secret and your
own freaking wife does not
and your family thinks that's good your
family's screwed up and then they left
you money so you don't have to work
that's screwed up
so let me tell you if you're going to
participate in the Ramsay trust it
involves continually working
because working is good for the soul
like real work yeah doing work showing
up and doing stuff you know this is not
good this is not healthy there's nothing
in this that's fun or it's only twenty
five thousand dollars only 300 000 a
year it's not like you're freaking rich
I mean it's 300 Grand jeez no I mean
really
no I mean it's not it's not three
million it's three hundred thousand and
what does this guy not done with his
life that he should have done pretty
good I I agree he should have done
something with his life instead he's the
king of words I mean oh my God I mean no
really I mean he could be sitting on
boards that's code for I don't do much
I'm telling you serious this is wrong
it's wrong
it's deception and it's all glassed over
as if my family has said we should not
share our money information because your
family thinks this money is a bigger
deal than it is it's just something I
think it's more important than your
spouse yeah and more important than your
integrity in your marriage yeah yeah
you've been living a long time in the in
the soup of deception and it's it's
poisoned your man really the cleanest
best thing you can do you'll be like an
alcoholic who sits down the bottle when
you quit lying you're going to have a
cleanliness of Soul that's going to be
so good for you and is she going to be
pissed well yeah
of course she's gonna be pissed she's
been lied to for 15 years
so yeah ah yeah yeah of course she's
gonna be mad yeah I mean she if she's
not she's a wuss she should be mad
this is just nutty anger is a good thing
yeah in that situation I mean really you
but you're you're living a lie that's
why you had to put it out on the dad gum
ethicist columnist page you have to go
to New York you have to go to ethics
class to figure this one out
this is why we need ethics classes
yeah son
don't and and papa don't do this to your
kids
you better off teach them how to work
and give them no money than give them
this crap